[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en Francia 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días estos son
los titulares abrimos esta edición con
el Día Mundial del cáncer de mama África
tiene una de las mayores tasas de
mortalidad por la enfermedad y según la
Organización Mundial de la Salud las
mujeres que mueren por ella son cada vez
más jóvenes y acuden al hospital en una
fase avanzada de la afección
analizaremos por qué vamos a echado
donde el general maham Mateo como
presidente Aunque este militar provecho
devolver el poder a los civiles seguirá
al frente del país durante dos años más
tras la prórroga de la transición
decidida al final de un diálogo nacional
boicoteado por la oposición y los
llevamos a mozambique en este país del
sur de África el gobierno se enfrenta en
un conflicto armado con grupos
yihadistas en la provincia Norteña de
cabo Delgado sin embargo en los últimos
meses en la ciudad de mosimboa 130.000
desplazados han podido volver a sus
casas después de que el ejército
nacional liberara la zona nuestra
corresponsal Marian con esto estuvo allí
para contarnos este regreso a menudo
difícil
el 19 de octubre se celebra el Día
Mundial del cáncer de mama el más mortal
para las mujeres de todo el mundo según
la Organización Mundial de la Salud en
2021 la enfermedad se convirtió en el
tipo más común de cáncer sobre todo en
los países más pobres donde es difícil
detectarla para hablar de ello nos
acompaña Miriam muteví oncóloga
especializada en cáncer de mama y
profesora en el Hospital Universitario
agacán de nairobi en Kenia
Miriam tevy Hola y gracias por estar con
nosotros Porque África es una de las
regiones donde más mueren las mujeres
por cáncer de mama creo que la Triste
realidad es que a pesar de los muchos
esfuerzos que estamos viendo la mayoría
de nuestras pacientes siguen siendo
diagnosticadas con un estado avanzado de
la enfermedad y muchas veces no
completan su tratamiento si nos fijamos
en las razones que hay detrás de esto
vemos una constelación de tres factores
principales uno es el hecho de tú te
sientes tienen que pagar de su propio
bolsillo para su atención médica lo que
resulta en una toxicidad financiera y
algunas veces en gastos de salud
catastróficos que les impiden continuar
con su terapia y la segunda gran Barrera
que vemos son los sistemas sanitarios
sabemos que en África subsahariana las
pacientes acuden a una media de 4 a 6
proveedores de atención sanitaria antes
de que se les diagnostique el cáncer de
forma definitiva y esto se ve además
agravado por las barreras
socioculturales que existen como el
estigma el uso de terapias alternativas
y el colectivismo donde la comunidad
Toma las decisiones por las mujeres todo
ello se traduce en última instancia en
retrasos en la atención y en el
diagnóstico qué cree que hay que poner
en marcha para combatir este fenómeno
creo que un enfoque multisectorial es
necesario definitivamente tenemos que
aumentar la concienciación sobre los
signos y síntomas comunes del cáncer y
tener estas conversaciones en las
comunidades pero si queremos informar a
nuestras comunidades también necesitamos
a trabajadores de salud comprometidos y
capaces de reconocer los signos y
síntomas de manera temprana y
necesitamos también instalaciones
oportunas de nuevo no hay sustituto a la
inversión por lo que requerimos que
nuestros gobiernos se inviertan
activamente en el cuidado sanitario y en
la prestación de atención para el cáncer
y realmente lo que estamos buscando es
una manera de establecer una cobertura
de tratamiento universal y sostenible
para que las personas puedan Acceder al
cuidado Sin temor a perder sus casas sus
medios de vida u otros ingresos qué
progreses han hecho hasta ahora en la
lucha contra la enfermedad en África
hemos visto bastantes esfuerzos y yo
diría que hemos tenido un par de
victorias por supuesto hemos visto más
países con un programa Nacional de
control de cáncer lo que realmente
representa el primer paso para reconocer
que hay un problema y para buscar cómo
tratarlo Ese es el primer paso y en los
últimos dos años se ha llegado a un 71%,
lo que supone un gran Progreso
ahora por supuesto El [__] está en los
detalles y en la implementación de estos
programas nacionales de control de
cáncer por ejemplo en Kenia tenemos un
fondo Nacional de seguro que ayuda a
mitigar algunos de los costos y hay un
tipo de fondo similar en gana y en otras
regiones pero lo que realmente se busca
es Cómo crear una cobertura más completa
y cómo ayudar a las pacientes a lo largo
de todo el proceso de la enfermedad
al principio de la entrevista usted
mencionó el estigma que sufren las
pacientes que se puede hacer para
cambiar la mentalidad
el estigma está muy presente en nuestras
comunidades decirle a una mujer en
África subsahariana que tiene un cáncer
significa decirle que podría perder a su
familia perder su fuente de ingresos
debido a la interseccionalidad del
stickmann
las pacientes son discriminadas en el
trabajo porque nadie piensa que son
competentes para seguir trabajando o
quizás porque tendrán que ir a visitas
al hospital y pedir tiempo libre la
comunidad también considera a veces que
el cáncer es algo contagioso y por eso
condena a las pacientes a los racismo
Así que se trata de ver cómo capacitamos
e informamos a nuestras comunidades de
que el cáncer no es contagioso es
tratable y si se detecta pronto y se
trata adecuadamente los resultados son
excelentes
similares a los que hemos visto en otras
partes del mundo
te vi Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros
seguimos con el tema de la salud en
gambia en los últimos meses al menos 69
niños han muerto por insuficiencia renal
aguda cuatro jarabes para la tos y la
fiebre están Implicados En las
defunciones de los menores y los
resultados de una investigación criminal
de la policía gambiana muestran que
todos ellos fueron producidos por El
fabricante Maiden farmacéuticos ubicado
en India según los primeros análisis de
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
estos productos fármacos estaban
contaminados con sustancias tóxicas La
muerte del primer menor Data del 16 de
julio Pero no fue hasta el 23 de
septiembre cuando se ordenó La retirada
de todos los jarabes el presidente de
gambia adama barrow ha ordenado medidas
de protección contra la importación de
medicamentos de baja calidad y la
creación de un es obligatorio de control
pero los familiares de las víctimas y
las organizaciones de la sociedad civil
denuncian que estas medidas llegan
demasiado tarde
Estamos consternados nos entristece y
hay que hacer justicia a estas víctimas
no sucederá pero nos aseguraremos de que
estas víctimas obtengan la justicia que
merecen Porque estos niños son Víctimas
de una negligencia médica y hemos
firmado un contrato social con el
presidente de gambia Adam barro su
función principal es proteger a los más
vulnerables y a fracasado
Lamentablemente
cambiamos de tema y pasamos ahora a chat
donde el general mahamed debe juro como
presidente tras 18 meses en el poder de
visi sigue al frente de una transición
militar que se prolongará dos años más
esta decisión fue tomada tras un diálogo
de Reconciliación nacional iniciado en
agosto además también podrá presentarse
a las elecciones presidenciales Aunque
había prometido lo contrario
el
Generalmente nombrado presidente de Chad
el general mahamad idris de vino es
designado presidente de la transición
presidente de la república jefe de
estado la toma de Posesión se produce en
un momento en el que el general de 38
años debería haber cedido el poder a los
civiles Pero en cambio mahama debbie ha
recibido las riendas del estado por
otros 24 meses y también podrá
presentarse a las próximas elecciones
esta decisión es la principal conclusión
del diálogo nacional que se Está
celebrando desde el 20 de agosto a pesar
del boicot de la mayoría de la oposición
el presidente tiene ahora más poderes y
puede elegir directamente a su Primer
Ministro lo que hizo nombrando a sale
quetzabo antiguo opositor de su padre
idris Davis
mis primeros pensamientos están
evidentemente con los chayanos con el
presidente de la república que me ha
dado su confianza para trabajar juntos
durante dos años para la transición
dando eso por cuando la transición en
abril de 2021 el presidente idris débil
fue asesinado por Rebeldes tras 30 años
en el poder mahatmad debbie fue
designado su sucesor por el ejército al
margen de toda legalidad institucional
en ese momento el general prometió
devolver el poder a los civiles mediante
lecciones tras una transición de 18
meses renovable una vez se había
comprometido con la comunidad
internacional a no presentarse a las
futuras elecciones presidenciales pero
pocos días después de sus promesas fue
respaldado en el funeral de su padre por
representantes de la unión africana y de
la Unión Europea incluida Francia
mientras sancionaban a militares
golpistas en otros países de África el
ejército chaviano es el principal Pilar
regional junto con el ejército francés
en la guerra contra los yihadistas en el
sahel
desde 2017 la insurgencia yadista azota
gran parte del norte de mozambique los
combates contra el ejército del país
afectan especialmente la provincia
Norteña de cabo Delgado ahí el grupo El
shabat Ha logrado tomar varias ciudades
como Palma y
praia el gobierno mozambiqueño pidió
ayuda militar a países como uruanda y
Botswana lo que le permitió retomar las
ciudades ocupadas en 2021 hoy aunque los
ataques continúan en la provincia varios
desplazados han podido regresar tras
años de exilio pero se enfrentan a
varios retos nuestra corresponsal
entrará en la región María Anthony
acompañó algunos de ellos a sus hogares
de origen
hace tres años miles de personas huyeron
de los ataques de la ciudad a través de
estas
aguasca
Después de tres años de tregua las aguas
de pocas veces han sido tan generosas
con Los Pescadores y vuelta desde hace
tres meses Alí es un dolor que ha podido
retomar su actividad
Por el momento no hemos tenido ningún
accidente y por lo que he oído nuestra
situación no es para quejarse no las
arreglamos para comer hastartarnos y
dormir tengo la suerte de poder salir
trabajar pescar comer con los niños
hoy a pesar de regreso de 130.000
personas muchos habitantes Especialmente
los jóvenes están desaparecidos
mataron a miembros de mi familia y
secuestraron a mis hijos todavía no sé
dónde están los rumores dicen que se
entrenan para el combate en el bosque
para la normal además de los jóvenes
secuestrados para engrosar las filas de
los guiadistas los retornados se
enfrentan a muchos dificultades como la
falta de registro Civiles para demostrar
su identidad
cuando llegaron dispararon en todas
direcciones Así que huimos a malandín a
toda prisa sin ningún objeto personal y
solo consigo recuperar esta bolsa de
plástico si los documentos de su esposa
y su hija soy esto aquí tapa no teníamos
nada eran estos documentos los que
estaban en mis cosas pero tengo suerte
porque mucha gente de mi pueblo perdió
sus documentos en el incendio perdí
fueron Kmart documentos desde el inicio
de la insurgencia en 2017 casi 4.000
personas han perdido la vida y casi un
millón son desplazados internos
así termina esta edición de África 7
días gracias por su sintonía nos vemos
la próxima semana
[Música]